i can be in a recession we are not in a
recession now the evidence is strong
we're not in a recessionary period the
data over the second quarter is not
consistent with an economy in recession
and why is it the white house officials
are trying to redefine
recession no we're not redefining
recession
president biden's prediction of there
being no recession recession lasting
about as long as kamala's doomed
presidential campaign the biden
recession is officially here and now
democrats are pushing even more massive
spending
for some reason to get us out of it buy
it in brushing off the bad economic news
while claiming uh well claiming dishing
out 700 billion dollars to do things
like fight climate change will actually
lower inflation
both chairman powell
and many of the uh
significant
banking personnel and economists
say we're not in recession we've created
nine million new jobs so far just since
we become president
businesses are investing in america at
record rates the inflation reduction act
will add another 370
billion dollars in clean energy tax
credits
in
reconciliation that doesn't sound like a
recession to me
i
fell asleep there and now that biden's
prediction has flopped democrats and the
media are getting on the same page to
try and convince americans you know that
things aren't that bad
we have to remember what difficult times
we're living in inflation isn't unique
to the united states it's happening
everywhere we're seeing is that we are
in a transition we are transitioning
clearly we're certainly in a transition
and we are seeing slowing as we all
would have expected recession the word i
think is now just a political football
always have faith that whether you agree
or don't stuff is getting done you don't
think that this is an indicator of an
impending recession or one already here
i don't this is the kind of reaction
that jerome powell might want to see
which is things cooling off oh jeez
wow that was painful rosanna welcome to
the show nice to see you from the fox
family thank you for inviting me to the
table and you know janine i'm sitting in
her seat nobody can fill her shoes but
she is my sister from another mister
with a law degree now there you go there
you go sisters yeah so what it seems to
me it was spending that got us into this
place and now they think that spending
can get us out of this i don't know
listen greg i'm not a wordsmith
but i feel like these politicians they
love to play semantics with us okay have
we not heard semantics before
sexual relations
recession we're getting screwed either
way right yeah very good i don't did you
like that
i figured i had to bring my a game with
it there you go there you go um i don't
know i go shopping i go to the grocery
store i have a family everything's gone
up butter eggs milk gas
is that transitory too i don't know it's
going on for a year and it's getting
worse well you know it's a great point
jesse that uh like while republicans and
generally non-liberals engage in the
real world by building things and
systems like practical stuff the dems
figure if you just change the language
the problems will disappear so a woman
is no longer a woman when you're dealing
with non-binary
and you know what are the there's so
many other examples uh well for example
sexual relations
and um that's what the crime that's what
they did in soviet russia they would
tell the population such
blatantly obvious lies
that no rational person would believe it
they'd say up is down black is white
there's no bread lines and you'd be
standing in the middle of a bread line
yeah and because there was no
independent media or no freedom of
speech the population really couldn't
challenge it
but
when you
try to challenge it they'll crush you so
you sit there and you take the lie you
take the lie you take the lie and then
the lies get bigger and that's what they
want they want to make the population
submissive because it doesn't matter if
you believe it it matters if you accept
it because once you accept the laws
you can you're basically just saying do
whatever you want with me and then they
can do whatever they want with you they
can control the population that way
we've never kind of had blatant
propaganda like this in this country
before until now
you know
men can get pregnant the border is
secure the afghanistan evacuation was
fantastic there was no laptop it was
fake this is not a recession we've never
tried to do this before but now you can
pull it off because
the press and and prosecutors and the
big tech monopolies are participating in
the lie
and they'll tell you you're a liar for
challenging it or they'll censor you or
they'll even investigate you but i like
the new thing about transition i think
it's brilliant
geraldo
we're not getting a divorce honey i am
transitioning to another house where i
will be sleeping with other women
data that is a transition i cannot abide
dana uh i am not stealing your jewelry
i am transitioning ownership
from you to me could you imagine a
football coach gets out there after a
loss and tells the fans guys
we didn't lose we're transitioning away
from our winning streak into a more
stable period of play do you know no
do you know when i got fired the first
time the hr person said they were
transitioning me out of my job there it
is and i just started laughing
from the job to the sidewalk yes it was
amazing i'll never forget that or the
guy who said that who's watching
probably
dana
so um
couldn't they done a better job of
explaining this like
why couldn't they have just been honest
maybe and said hey look these are unique
circumstances we're coming out of a out
of a a pandemic you know instead they
just decided to play with the words well
it's interesting too because why
wouldn't you just do that if 75 percent
of the country
65 of the country thinks we're in a
recession already yeah 75 percent of
democrats don't want joe biden to run
again
like 85 of the country thinks that we're
on the wrong track so adding recession
is just i don't understand why it was
such a big deal because the story then
became that the white house was so
worried about the word recession that
they would do anything to try to get you
not to say it now a lot of media went
along with it but this is the technical
definition imagine george w bush or
donald trump trying to get away with
this and the media would never have done
that and that's fine because you have to
be honest about what's happening um you
have to wonder who the spin is actually
for then it's for twitter yeah and it's
for the media and people at home they
know what's happening as rosanna just
said and you have a restaurant as well
i'm sure that you know that all those
costs have gone up but you've got
customers you want them to keep coming
back wait you have staff that you want
you have a restaurant yes fresco by
scotto you have
everybody's been here no not jesse
because i'm not in his world last night
but anyway um
geraldo was there dana yes everyone's
got to go i just want to say one other
thing there's a because the restaurant's
great we should get to it
the next word they're going to try to
redefine is stagflation right oh yeah
okay because speculation is when you
have uh slowing growth
high on inflation and low unemployment
and that means that you are really in
the soup but that'll be the next word
that they try to say well that's not
really stagflation because they keep
pointing to the job market they'll say
wait till next week the jobs are going
to be super strong right well if you
have to have three jobs the job market
is going to be strong well i thought
stagflation was when the stripper gets
pregnant at the stag party
[Laughter]
there you are redefining words again
yeah yes i redefined stack relationship
transistor you know uh geraldo the other
there also is this strategy we were
talking about before the show of
introducing a bill that nobody can
possibly read and and and therefore not
even the media reads it we're gonna read
it we haven't had time to read it but no
one else is gonna nobody reads it but
the lobbyists but i i i will say this
that i have absolutely no problem first
of all i welcome rosanna thank you bob
scotto
you and the judge are like sisters
uh so uh you're like their hairy sister
yeah i'm the hairy sister so you have
two consecutive quarters of negative gdp
so that's technically a recession
charles payne neil cavuto say it's a
recession so i agree it's a recession
but in terms of the bill that nobody
reads
as i i have no particular problem i
don't know why anyone would with the top
50 corporations paying 15 percent
minimum tax they pay no tax now biden if
president biden is telling the truth and
it's and 50 of our largest corporations
do not pay any
federal income tax
then i want them to pay some money i'm a
capitalist i'm a republican but i still
want these big corporations to pay
something rather than basing in the
bahamas or you know the channel islands
and you're using that as a tax dodger
but why does every it's like every every
problem to them is a nail
right and and and they just use the
hammer of taxes exactly why can't they
just try to solve a problem without
burdening people that actually create
things but isn't that a isn't that a
problem that the 50 top no
profitable corporations
because i don't believe that that's true
and i think that the way that occurs
because because i think that the way
that the congress has set the tax laws
they're not saying
nobody is saying that the corporations
are doing something illegal they are
following the tax code but the congress
can't see its way to legislate anything
so instead they'll just say well let's
just add a tax to it and then to pay for
what what are you going to get for that
money where are they going to get for
that additional money and do you think
that those costs aren't going to be
passed down right on downtown among
other things
excuse me but they claim that over 300
billion dollars will be taken off the
deficit so that benefits the average
american
rather than these corporations getting
all this profit and distributing it as
dividends
which only helps their uh their fat cats
well we'll see i mean the other thing is
almost all of them are on record saying
that you should not raise taxes in a
recession
we'll see if they stick to that
great way to end this segment i went to
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now